[Musique]
chers amis des républicains
je m'adresse à vous en tant que
présidente de notre mouvement fonction
que j'occupe depuis le 4 juillet dernier
après la démission de christian jacob je
présidais ce soir mon premier bureau
politique et l'ordre du jour comportait
un point principal qui concerne les
modalités d'élection à la tête de notre
mouvement cette élection je peux
désormais vous le dire puisque ce
calendrier a été validé à l'unanimité
cette élection aura lieu en deux tours
si nécessaire les 3 et 4 décembre et les
10 et 11 décembre
les candidats pourront valider présenter
leurs parrainages jusqu'au 3 octobre et
naturellement nous vous tiendrons au
courant des différents développements de
ce processus très important pour notre
famille politique élire un nouveau
président ou une nouvelle présidente
s'est lui donner une pleine légitimité
pour agir pour mobiliser les énergies au
sein de notre mouvement pour accompagner
nos groupes parlementaires dans le
travail très important qu'ils conduisent
désormais de façon la plus coordonnée
possible au sein d'une dune da travail
partenarial que j'ai mise en place dès
mon arrivée et puis je veux aussi que
nous puissions aller
auprès de nos fédérations auprès de nos
adhérents de militants qui ont fourni un
travail formidable à l'occasion des
élections législatives et je veux les en
remercier je vous dis donc à très
bientôt et je vous souhaite à tous un
très bel
[Musique]